president trump says he has nothing to
do with the potential prosecution of
hunter biden
or the biden family democrats are not
buying that
we're also getting new information about
an attempt to get joe biden directly
involved
in one of the suspect deals we'll get
the latest fallout from the ongoing
scandal and the federal investigations
from senior political correspondent
mike emanuel hunter biden's former
business associates were hinting at a
push to get joe involved
in a joint venture with chinese energy
company cefc
hoping to make it look like a truly
family business that's according to text
messages obtained by fox news
on may 11 2017 hunter's former
associates james gilliar and tony
bobolinsky
corresponded on text with gilliard
writing man you are right
let's get the company set up then tell h
and family the high stakes
and get joe involved more republicans
are now saying it's time for a special
counsel
i don't know any other way to be
absolutely certain
that the investigation of hunter biden
would be thorough enough and done an
appropriate manner
republicans are concerned about the
calendar recognizing january
20th is about a month away traditionally
when a new president comes in they fire
all the u.s attorneys
if he wants to show that this is going
to be a upright
upstanding biden administration and that
they're going to
actually let the cards lie where the
cards lie on hunter biden
he needs to leave that u.s attorney in
place joe biden will not interfere
that's not in his dna just not in his
dna
and he believes in the rule of law and
i'll guarantee it'll be done in in a
proper way and i feel very confident
about that
president trump tweeted this morning i
have nothing to do with the potential
prosecution of hunter biden or the biden
family
but a judiciary democrat says this is
all about the president the
whole focus on hunter biden seems to be
a distraction
for president trump it shouldn't be for
us
a longtime member the senate judiciary
committee says he does have a concern
i just hate to see a proliferation of
special counsel
they are not accountable to anybody in
particular
drip drip drip of new revelations could
be making it more difficult for biden to
find an attorney general nominee
knowing that questions about the hunter
biden probe will be front and center
during the confirmation process
brett mike thank you